[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality
best-selling author redefining anxiety
is my co-host today
michael going into the break from san
antonio is getting married in january
his fiancee is 200 000
in debt for a phd in physical therapy uh
pt's typically make about 80 grand he's
working for a commercial real estate
company making 23
and uh when he finishes his master's in
real estate
finance will move into brokerage he's
wanting to know figure out how to pay
off the 200 000
in student loan debt as they get married
and that's how we left him at the break
does that sound right michael did i get
all that correctly
that sums it up okay cool all right so
let's go back i want to get i want to
dig down a little bit deeper into the
actual steps and what you guys should do
and shouldn't do how old are you two uh
we're 23.
okay and when does she finish school
uh may 2022 so she's got a year and a
half
left right the clinicals is the last
year
okay um i'm unfamiliar with pt clinicals
in the sense that does she get paid
no she does not does she pay for that
uh living expenses okay well we got that
covered you're married and so
okay and you're making 23 000 for how
much longer
um i want to say about eight to nine
more months
okay then it'll be commission only and
then you'll be straight commission
commercial real estate broker
yes when will your masters be completed
may 2022 as well and your cash flowing
that how
uh i'm with this money that i make we're
living at home with my parents
and you plan to do that ongoing after
you're married
it's not ideal uh but that's just how it
happens okay
all right because here's what i hear in
the map
and i i um that's disturbing
you're going to have zero income
for approximately the next two years
within i mean you have 23 000 until
you start your full-time brokerage and
then you're going to make nothing
until you sell a piece of commercial
real estate and commercial real estate
i've been in real estate my whole life
it's not rabbit hunting it's elephant
hunting
there aren't many of them and when you
kill one you eat well but it takes a
while and you better have your bullet in
your gun when you get there
so um 23 years old to close a 10 million
property
uh 24 years old uh is it can be done
i did it at that age but um but it's
it's
it's it's hard it's a very very hard
track you put yourself on
um and you know if you if the market
booms
in san antonio texas and you're able to
move three or four pieces of property by
the time you're 25 or 26
she lands an 80 000 position you guys
can begin working your way through this
but i hear two or three years
of almost no income
that's just not cool i think we need a
different plan
and living with your parents trying to
keep
a new marriage stable trying to pay off
would you say 160 grand in
student loan debt for her well it
doesn't kick in for 18 more months until
she gets out
right it's just a big number and it's
you know i'm looking at it in the future
well what i'm looking at man is two
years living with mom and dad
two years of you're going to figure out
a way to go for making 23 000
a year getting a masters and making less
and then you're going to be two years
into living at home two years into a new
marriage
two years into not making any money two
years into her
finishing grinding out clinicals which
is a tough medical clinicals are hard
man
they take a lot of your heart mind and
soul you were just adding stressor on
top of stressor on top of stressor
and for this fragile new marriage living
at your parents house for 24 months 36
months man that's a tough way to get
shot out of the cannon let's pretend
there's not 200 000
in student loan debt okay okay what
you're prescribing
or what you've lined up with almost no
income for 24 months
and living in your parents house in your
first year while she's doing clinicals
in your first year of marriage
there's a lot of stress there a lot
there's like five layers before we get
to the student loans
and it's all related to a lot it's all
related to a lack of income
and so i'm not sure you're going to be
able to stay on the track you're going
to be able to stay on and keep your
young family and your marriage
healthy emotionally because you're going
to be doing it with almost
no income and it's somebody else's rules
right
i mean you talk to the brokers in your
in your uh who are you working for
which which company cushman wakefield no
we're out of austin
equitable commercial realty it's a it's
a small firm
uh but we primarily do office leases so
it's not
just you know building sales it's
primarily leases
yeah which is a little a little quicker
than
full building sales but you know you
still got to work it out plus or minus
pandemic
right two years from now
after two years of zooming under our
belts it's gonna be a very interesting
proposition brother on office space
um you know and leasing yeah leasing you
can close the lease and and
you can start getting some money in if
that's where you're making most of your
money anyway i would sit and talk to
your broker and say in the current
environment
with this lot product line when do you
see me actually making money when i go
to brokerage don't hype my butt tell me
what the typical guy in here does
and i'm 24 years old at this point
trying to do this
can i do it now hey man i was selling
real estate at your age residential
while i was in school i was younger than
you at 20 21
and interest rates went to 17 the market
was impossible
and i still sold some houses but it's
just because i worked
all the time and i out you know i sold
houses in spite of the fact that i was
21 years old with a magnum pi mustache
wearing a disco suit
you know and people still bought houses
from me right because all i did was just
outwork
my youth outwork my stupidity outwork my
ignorance
you're way sharper than i was then but i
kind of had the same dream that's why i
wanted to talk to you a little bit
further because i wanted to be a
commercial real estate guy that's what i
wanted to be
and first job out of school is i did
syndication deals which they don't do
anymore but
so i i i'm i'm worried about your lack
of income
if you can get more comfortable with
your income as soon as she kicks in
let's say you start making 100 a guy
doing what you're talking about doing in
a normal
economy after a little bit of time to
build up some credibility and build up a
pipeline you can make 100 a year doing
what you're talking about
you could make 200 a year doing what
you're talking about she's gonna she
should make in the 80 range
and so if you're making a hundred to a
hundred to two hundred thousand dollars
a year you can pay off 200 000
in student loan debt student loan is bad
it's horrible but
it doesn't scare me for you guys like
this thing where you make zero money so
you need to sit down talk to your broker
and get some realistic
expectations and then start figuring out
is there a side job
or is the is the brokerage thing a side
job while i get
uh well i feed my new wife and we get a
household
because i gotta tell you she's gonna be
living with her mother-in-law while
she's doing medical clinicals
i i don't care how great a woman your
mom is that's a hard that's a hard
prescription
that's a tough one it's a real and in 90
of the households it's beyond tough
right
uh you know occasionally you have the
i've got a friend whose
mother-in-law is her idol but you know
how unusual that is you know so
uh um and it may be that you put your
your commercial real estate dream on
hold on
and get a little bit to feed your young
30 or 40 000 your job
get an apartment and y'all grind it out
she's got a year and a half left and
then when she starts
making money it's not a bad idea then
you go if that's still what you want to
do
right yeah um or go get your license and
start selling
uh residential real estate for a couple
of years until you can
and you won't lose anything by that no
you can make your move
and you got a better shot of selling
houses um
you know uh but it can be done it could
be done i mean i would
i you're just man you're just stacking
the deck against your new marriage
you're stacking the deck against your
i'm just trying to think the cuffs from
a customer experience standpoint
we've leased offices winston yeah my
son-in-law
you know we're the customer and so would
we sit down with a 24 year old and do a
lease deal
yeah as long as he knew his stuff right
i'm not going to hold his age against
him but you better know your dadgum
stuff or you're gonna get filleted
but i also would want to know does the
the folks in his firm if
if dave ramsey calls and says i want to
do an office a deal are they gonna let
the 24 year old go run out and do that
or are they going to put you keep
rolling you back to the bottom of that
pile there that's a good point
you were on your own dave when you work
for a firm that's true first in gets
this
the the stuff that falls to the moment
please study the income side of this
equation and the housing side of this
equation
and try to lower the number of stressors
as long as you guys get your incomes
moving by 25 years old i think you're
gonna be able to handle the 200 000
maybe easier than some of the other
stuff
that's what's scaring me for you young
man and um
we we we want nothing but good things
for you i can tell you that
this is the dave ramsey show